they oppose the right-handed sonny gray
his numbers from western and southern
well the numbers do not
really dictate what this man brings to
this club this is their stopper this is
the motivational
leader of this staff doesn't have the
best numbers
yet but certainly the grinder mentality
that bulldog get after you that's what
sunny gray brings to the ball game every
single time
let's see what nolan arenado can do is
arnado
is two out of nine in the series a
double a walk
looking for his 20th home run and he'll
take the base hit to left
nice easy swing for arnado and he gets
on for tyler o'neill with two outs in
the first inning
oh neal a drive into center
naquin back gone it's a home run
two to nothing cardinals on a blast off
the bat of tyler o'neil
[Applause]
and now it's johan oviedo on the mound
for st louis we love giving johan obiedo
a lead to work with here in the first
inning he could go out
and not that it should change your
mindset very much with the stuff that he
has
india for the series four out of eight
three-run score to walk
and the 2-2 right down the middle struck
him out
good start for oviedo and the reds have
two on with one out ahead of joey votto
daunting it bad if you're an opposing
pitcher
and he unleashes a towering
shot three run homer
but that looked like a fastball just
over the plate beautiful swing and yes
he is swinging a super hot bat
joey votto is a cardinal killer
opposite way sliding stop freeman with
the lunge snaps off the throw
nice play and look at the quick reaction
by freeman at third base
that's a great play
bounces this one up the middle farmer
nice job
tough play for freeman jump throw from
foul ground on a bounce into live
oh my carlson pretty quick down the line
but
what a play by mike freeman
mike schilt wants them to take a look so
this is a huddle first
well you saw the umpires they were
saying let's go mike let's go make a
decision
there was a lot of rumbling from the
reds dugout time's up time's up let's go
they didn't go to the headset they
talked with each other and i think they
determined chill
didn't ask for the review in time it
feels like shilt almost wants to get run
here
that hangs aquino can motor covers a ton
of ground and a cato
into the wall makes the catch well we
saw aquino
making a play earlier stopping right
before that wall
that time the tumble over the wall while
you were gone
mike schilt got his money's worth he
just went
at the men in blue there's a lot of lip
reading here
i think john boy is going to have some
fun with this one
and whatever he said led to him being
ejected from the game culpa tossed him
and he had more to say as well to the
home plate umpire chad fairchild
so runners had first and second base hit
for paul de young and now tommy edmond
cardinals have something going here
top of four trailing by a run eight two
one pitches hit hard and deep to center
field
backing up is the center fielder and
it's off the wall
one runs going to score de young heads
to third a double for
tommy edmond off the center field wall
and the cardinals have tied it at three
runners at second and third harrison
bader still nobody out
and banner launches one and a deep left
at the wall gone
three run homer harrison bader
his second bomb in this series and it
puts the red birds on top
dylan carlson at the plate 1-1 pitch
is hit deep to right field if it's fair
it's a big fly
and this is long gone a home run for
dylan carlson
the cardinals third home run of the game
their
sixth run of the inning and it's now
eight to three
cardinals a six run inning
sonny gray tagged with three home runs
oronato fly ball left field
and off the top of the wall come on
nolan
help me out here but head on over to
third
i'll take a triple
and that gets through arenado will score
and that will make it nine to three
cardinals
bases loaded and he has to face
aristides aquino
got him strikeout for hell's lead
two outs and kyle farmer will be a
little more difficult to handle
and it's popped up hellsly will get out
of the jam
the young under it puts it away and it
stays 9-3 as we head to the sixth
two away in the sixth inning and now
tyler stevenson two on
two out and his eyes for the hole sneaks
on through wave is on they'll challenge
o'neill
he could see it's the score lollipop
tossed to third base
tyler stevenson aboard four times
singles in
the reds fourth run for one
reached on a walk in his first advance
struck out his last time
uh runners at second and third for the
rents cabrera to the plate
and it's grounded down the right field
line and that's headed into the corner
two runs will score truck on
to second base that's the double and
it's now a nine
six goal games reds are trying to come
from behind against this st
louis team but you got to get
goldschmidt here the 1-2 swinging a
ground ball
votto a nice backhand pick and he
underhands desantion covering into bags
for the out i don't know how he caught
that ball
eighth pitch of the plate appearance
he's out of the zone and he walks
wow oh my goodness
enes cabrera drew a diagram for home
plate umpire
chad fairchild tell them imma go
upstairs and watch and look
and see but i know that ball was a
strike and the reds
have loaded the bases in the eighth
inning first pitch to him
popped up right side playable
goldie he's got it gallegos strands the
bases loaded
and gets out of the jab arnado with a
triple and a run scored
arenado with a drive out to left
gone over the wall
in a hat and number 20 this year for
nolan oronato
cardinals were looking for a little bit
of insurance they
get it here so it indeed is a home run
and a big day for nolan oronato who's
now a double shy
of the cycle reds are down to their last
out
and here is shogo akiyama on japanese
american community day
akiyama ground ball right side
backhanded tommy edmond and the
cardinals
salvage a game beating cincinnati today
10 to six